[Music]
hey folks here we are we might be drunk
we're really doing it the bartender's
late but [ __ ] him he's a rabid raging
alcoholic
uh
we gotta we got a guest today tommy
segura what's shaking fetty what's up
man good to have you we're pumped to
have you man we're just talking clubs
before we're rolling just talking i mean
so you'll still hit clubs when you
are working out the hour yeah yeah yeah
that's what i did for this uh this
current hour
i did i mean i kind of did it for
i would have done it more continuously
it wasn't for
that 2020 thing yeah it happened but it
was um
yeah it was all like club weekends and
then building building and then you go
like all right like i can take it to
a theater show now but yeah that's the
way to do it i think do you are there
certain cities that you want to hit
every time
um
i stay in lexington once actually i
enjoyed that that's a great club yeah
how many off broadway that's it
yeah that's a good one um i love doing
the ice house like i told you in
pasadena that's a good one then there's
like clubs that you just you personally
have so much comfort in so like uh the
brea improv for me is where i like first
did a feature set whoa what did you
feature for
uh
actually the very first time was cosby i
got i got promoted during the weekend oh
bad host
well had a rough go okay it was a tell
wow yeah
what
yeah
wow holy [ __ ] well that's gotta feel
good to get promoted yeah it was with a
tail
yeah the king and i was like
super [ __ ]
like like a child like like you know
like a kid with like lebron i was like
like staring at him
he's like do you ever blink like feel
like that you know yeah
and like he gets more shout outs on this
podcast than i think any comic i have a
[ __ ] like whole chapter about him
we've i've told your story that actor
thing uh-huh i've told that on this
podcast have you heard that what i think
i told him
i don't think we told him on this
podcast well i'll let you tell it
because it's it's so good oh yeah cause
so
i so that weekend i got to end up
featuring for him it was my first time
featuring
a weekend for the improvs and for anyone
and i was like you know i was like i'm a
feature now like it was amazing right
and then i started to get work from them
like that and then
the next year so like a year has gone by
i get a call i'm working a day job
they're like hey um do you want to work
like this coming weekend at the uh
improv and bray i was like yeah sure
they go you've been requested
and i was like oh by who they go and
they go david tell and i'm like wow
right so i was like [ __ ] yes
so
i'm working the weekend and i'm like now
i'm a little more
confident and
i start you know
i think we do like thursday show and
then after the first show friday we're
in the green room
and he was like uh
you don't have like a you don't have 20
new minutes i was like what
and he's like
i mean you did some of those jokes last
year and i was like
oh uh
yeah i guess he goes i mean do you want
to be like an actor or something oh my
god from him hearing it from him
yeah that is wow and i was like i mean
kinda yeah
but then i was like [ __ ] i mean
yeah it was like i mean it makes you
right what a favor he did you though he
did like multiple favorites yeah
that's also the uh the weekend where
i was like you know everybody everybody
at that time so this would have been
like 2006.
everybody was putting out albums albums
were still like a hot thing and it was
like kind like
they were you know comedy central
records and all these like record
companies and comedians were just like
that was the thing i've got a new album
oh yeah so and he was like almost most
famous for skanks for the memories which
was yeah an album yeah so
every comic talked about that so i was
like yeah i uh
i'm thinking i go i'm wondering if i
should put out an album you know like i
think i wonder if i should record an
album and he's like [ __ ] you know
smoking yeah and he goes do you have an
hour you love
and i was like
uh no he
goes then like i thought about it and i
was like oh yeah that and i didn't
record anything for another like
four years wow yeah i mean i definitely
wasn't ready then anyway
but it was like here
if he hadn't said that or i hadn't heard
that from someone i probably would have
been like i should probably do something
you know yeah i just feel like this is
so it's like from a dude who cares
that's yeah and it's like a brain give a
[ __ ] it's a great uh exactly um but it's
also a great thing like when someone's
like i wonder if i should record it's
like do you have an hour you love right
now yeah is it ready yeah you know
because people want the glitz and the
glam the glory and the clicks hey good
for you man but it's
always too soon i feel like especially
now now now it's like people are putting
up like their first set like i know
i'm sure you get it uh too where like
people send it to you they're like hey
will you watch this yes you don't want
me dude you're like dude i don't want i
really don't want to watch this you want
me to watch it less right i'll watch it
in four years when you hate it too yeah
yeah and then we can have a laugh about
it right right yeah tell is uh you know
he's all of our favorites whatever but
like still to this day i think all right
i think he respects me now and he'll see
me they'll go hey you got anything new
and i'm like
so now i have to do a bit yeah to you
and so then i i'll do like one and he's
like yeah yeah
come on
he doesn't give no but you know and the
craziest thing was that when um so i did
uh
back in september
uh pete had this like um fundraiser show
september 11 thing right where like and
it was like yeah at the garden yeah so
it's all it's all these comics on it
right and
and then tells on there he [ __ ] had
the most he brought out a recorder yeah
yeah
but then backstage it was so funny
because we're all everybody is like
i tell right he is sitting there [ __ ]
joking with everybody yeah like trying
to make you laugh
the entire time right backstage
and i was like we were all just sitting
there like the [ __ ] like yeah you know
i was like i was like should we be
trying to do this too right
no it was just him yeah he's he but he's
tough too because like one time uh we
were on the stoop at the cellar and he's
smoking he has that filter on his
cigarette and like i watched three
people come and go what is that thing
dave and he goes apparently it's a
conversation
[Music]
[Laughter]
he just knows how to get you guys really
have the same thing i do where like you
kind of like have the built-in belief in
the hierarchy sure sure so like i don't
like i'll try i'll be
like oh cool to like a guy 10 years
older than me but i don't feel like
we're peers no i'm the same way for sure
no we have a lot of respect for the i
mean look i mean look at the walmart we
you know we yeah we love comedy yeah of
course
yeah i mean
a tell is still a dude i'm like i saw
him in high school like caroline's wow
did you really yeah i have a little
playbill that he autographed wow i was a
dumb kid it was like david tell this
guy's the greatest so uh no we still
feel we talk about it we still feel we
weird that we know him yeah we don't
ever want to overstep right right
greatest ever yeah yeah but what about
this one what if you say a guy who's 10
years old or whatever but you don't
respect his stuff that's totally
different that's totally different
then you're like hey what's up man yeah
yeah yeah that's true if you don't
respect them yeah hey
beer jew hey
how are you beard
good what are you making today today
we're doing uh some bodega cat whiskey
showers
this is this is our whiskey by the way
yeah we marked our own way we're trying
to sell a booze here yeah bodega cat you
guys like this is yours yeah
yeah yeah we're going for it we're going
for it unlike ron white we didn't quit
drinking
16 months way to go ron hey good for you
he's good he's trying to stay alive yeah
good for him yeah once your hair is that
white yeah but beautiful head of hair on
that bottom
[ __ ]
it looks like romance not like fabio
yeah yeah dude exactly
kreicher though
he's he's going
the hair
uh everything else yeah well i didn't
want to get over the neglect yeah but
yeah look at that oh my god jesus christ
like like a southern fabio yeah it
really is
damn yeah he's got a great head of hair
it really is great yeah drunk in public
out talking about albums that's one of
the best albums ever
yeah so solid he's a great guy i met him
uh
for the first time like a month ago and
he was couldn't been cooler yeah he's
like the oh like you're talking about
storytelling yes he's like the og like
storyteller oh tater salad when that
came out that like
blew the roof off yeah
what uh so when you were doing these
clubs like what what other cities will
you hit besides like great i know bray
is like classic yeah anything else let's
see uh
dean i'll do like i did like i think i
did dayton you know because it was like
out like it's like you want to do kind
of
club you know
almost like go into secondary markets
more i think because you're like you
want to save like your primo markets oh
yeah i'm hitting fort wayne indiana this
year there you go that's it that's how
to do it yeah tough room yeah the
lexington room um i'm trying to think
of the other ones um
comedy zones i've done i've done those
uh i did like the uh omaha um
that's a solid solid club really good
club it's one of those chains but it's
like a mom and poppy version yeah and
they have like a built-in great fan base
yeah there what about like are there any
uh cities or clubs never again
oh yeah yeah here we go wuhan
what do you think
uh i don't want to go to erie um ah i
dine in erie
that's a clean room isn't it
they want you to be clean jokers juniors
juniors last laugh yeah that was it i
did it once and the guy was like you got
to be clean i'm talking squeaky and he
hosted he went up and he's like so i was
[ __ ] my son in the ass
yeah he didn't have to be clean that
that that guy's they were [ __ ] it was
because of they sold it though so it's
not the same owners now okay so that
clean thing came from this woman who
bought the club and her husband would
work the bar and
and he would like pull yourself you got
to be clean you guys have said this like
eight times man yeah and then
i remember i did a set where i worked
clean i did a clean
45 or whatever it was then and then when
i got off stage the lady goes did you
say penis oh
my god i go what she goes one of the
servers said that you said penis i go
isn't that the proper way to describe
the anatomy she was like i guess like
that now wow wow i guess
i mean it was just a nightmare and then
what a pain i asked if i go has anyone
ever like said they're gonna
work clean and then just ghost and they
were like yes i've seen that a lot ago
it was jb smooth
so he said that he was like yeah all
right all right and then he goes all
right you ever know like a [ __ ]
and he just starts like [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah he said he gets off
stage
the guy goes
what are you doing he goes what he goes
you said [ __ ] like a thousand
times and he goes man you can't put
handcuffs on me man
so they fire they go you gotta go wow
wow yeah i hope for him once it
caroline's
obsessed i don't know if i've laughed
that hard in my life uh but he was
sweating so he did a whole bit about
[ __ ] a girl
like uh doggy style and first of all he
comes out to ba
you know and it's all jews all like new
york jews who love curb
12 minutes in they just start walking
out
because they're like what the [ __ ] is
this you know it was so filthy and uh i
was loving it it's not like leon is a
squeaky clean character on curb no but
they're what they have
i don't know you just saw a bunch of
yarmulkes filing out it was great
yes the exodus
yeah that one i've heard that one's
tough i remember joe mack used to do
that one he was
that that's uh
are there any others that you're like
that's just rough
uh as far as like [ __ ] clubs yeah man
i'm trying to think of like places i
would
you try to block them out you know yeah
there's like there's like these
depressed
communities one of the cedars i don't
remember i think it's uh oh never been
there maybe it's falls or the one i'm
not playing coming up
where i was like i don't want like you
get off you're like i don't want to do
this again um yeah i just did uh
tunica mississippi on this tour you know
whoa because we did like a southern room
i mean it's not at the top of my i gotta
go backless
yeah yeah um yeah yeah there's some that
you just like the [ __ ] is happening here
yeah so i'm doing that burt fully loaded
thing and you know party's like should i
do this you know am i gonna ruin some of
my tickets oh right you know if we go to
the same cities but the cities are like
bristol tennessee
some town in mississippi i've never
heard of and i'm like oh we'll be fine
you'll be fine yeah yeah but he sells
he's selling out like baseball stadiums
in a bristol tennessee is that crazy for
you that you were doing these i mean
like your dude that we looked at were
like he's a road dog he's doing it the
right way and you're selling out these
in like arenas now it is crazy i can't
believe like i can't believe that
because i remember we were talking about
people doing arenas like
five years ago having these
conversations and being like
oh you don't you can't uh
plan
an arena
like career you know like no it's like
we were just talking like how it just ha
it has to just happen
right so and it just seems silly like
when they go
hey you have here's an offer for like
when the offer comes in you're like to
do the uh where the basketball team
plays yeah it does seem crazy yeah it's
crazy then we added one we
know where in denver
wow so this is you see like nicola
yokish's face in the locker room
jokes here it's [ __ ] crazy yeah it
doesn't it doesn't feel
real but the other thing that i mean you
probably get this too already is like
you do weirdly adapt pretty quickly to
things totally you know yeah like
that's what i think that's what comics
do and then you start going like oh we
didn't add one yeah you know it gets uh
boring quick not boring but it gets
ordinary quick yeah yeah you get really
used to it yeah you get really used to
it is it but i mean doing arenas i mean
it's like a whole different thing i mean
it's totally different you also realize
that you um
it is the opposite of intimacy yeah like
doing the seller is like very intimate
right you're just like any like small
club
you know and then you realize that when
you do the arenas it's it's like they're
watching us the special right because
they're all like most of them are just
like looking at that screen that's true
so you're you're kind of performing
to the like you're not like you know
what's up like man yeah just like
you're just like putting on almost like
you
learn the lines and you put on the show
exactly exactly i bombed at the
kalamazoo whatever that arena is and i'm
still scarred really i'm still in the
shower four years later like oh that was
bad what i was were you just like
it it started late and they were like
you gotta go up now and they were
seating they were everything for amy
right yeah amy schubert and uh it was
the worst day of my life because she
goes i'm to give you a comedy central
special i'm going to produce it i'm like
oh my god it's the biggest deal of my
life and she's like so i'll watch she
never watched you know she was in the
green room getting ready so she's at the
side of the stage like this and i'm just
pouring sweat i'm talking you could hear
a mouse queef it was 20 000 people
zero noise except for like
is this my seat who's that is that who
had this seat are you here can i sit
here you know i was like oh god and
you're bringing out like the save jokes
you're like everything every liner like
this one will turn it around i'll get
something yeah i was like should i go
michael richards that might get him
then i'd wake him up a little i'd get
some response
it was brutal [ __ ] horrific feeling
kalamazoo is a rough a lot of camo hats
i bombed i bombed him
there was a club there that i remember
my bomb yeah
home of uh home of derek jeter oh thank
you
hey uh i'm excited wait what do we got
again what is this this is a typical um
uh whiskey sour with potato cat all
right great
in there too now i know you got a tv
tape in it
we'll have a little bit just you'd have
to drink all of it there yeah that's
really good cheers
there we go might as well
yeah dennis taping colbert today is i
mean i think i actually first time i met
you you were doing panel on conan i was
on stand up on there yeah was that your
first time doing panel or no i don't
remember i don't know you've done it a
bunch now though right a few times not
that many times um
it's fun i mean i like it i remember i
was like oh man cause you were really
good and you were really good i was i
was pumped that i was following you
because you want to follow a comic yeah
yeah and i think who did i go i was out
there with lisa kudrow on that i
remember whoa
yeah i love lisa yeah she was awesome
dude michelle's high school reunion yeah
yeah underrated yeah she was great
yeah she's awesome um yeah panel is is a
it's way less pressure than doing a set
of course it is but also
you can kind of just be
i mean i guess they expect you to be
funny because comedian but like you're
following an actor usually you're in the
same seat like there is an advantage in
some ways you just come out and you're
like here's jokes you know yeah yeah but
i don't know panel panel looks more fun
it's fun it's fun i mean else but you
you like they do the pre-interview you
know when they talk to you for like like
40 minutes
and then you don't know because like the
person interviewing you is laughing like
it's a phone call yeah and then you're
like all right and they're like
all right we'll like tomorrow we'll
figure out what we want to do about this
and then you're like i wonder if they
like do they like the stuff that it was
kind of like throw away where you're
like that wasn't that like what if they
what if that's what they want to do yeah
and then the thing that you thought was
the most solid they're like
oh interesting so you just don't know
which way because then what happens is
you show up and they go we're going to
do this remember we talked about these
things we're going to do these three and
you're like really you want to do those
three right you know now if you just
went off the beaten path and said [ __ ]
it i'm doing whatever what would they be
like we can't have him back he's a
little probably yeah probably unless
you're like a huge [ __ ] star yeah
because like gervais could probably just
go out there but i got it i got it yeah
i think they said that i asked one time
because i did that with conan a few
times uh
i was like what do you do with like will
like isn't like will ferrell would do
conan all the time jim carrey and they
were like oh yeah he'll just be like i
want to wear a [ __ ]
chef's hat and
gotta go with it they're like okay yeah
um but you know it'll be gold yeah or
like i said i mean because burr would go
on there and just like
murder oh yeah i followed him once on
conan and it was it might have been my
best set ever because he's doing it was
when he was doing that caitlyn jenner
well he's like give it a minute you know
like that whole bit and i was like holy
[ __ ] he's killing so hard and i was like
i was pumped i was like i had a few
drinks in the green room and i was it
was like the loosest i've ever been and
i'm like holy [ __ ] this is like i'm
saying following you if i own bill burr
it's like the dream spot right yeah
because nothing i say is going to shock
them after burr's doing a kaitlyn jenner
baby sure yeah yeah i asked i go how
does he what they go we literally
call him right when like yeah we want
you to do thursday
and they're like so like what's on your
mind
and then he's just like
[Laughter]
women suck all right we'll see you
thursday like that
whoa
that's the dream yeah but you i mean
you've done it a few times so it's like
it was conan one of your guys where you
kind of like [ __ ] out i'm getting
interviewed by conan there's a crowd
like it's different than podcasting you
get to still be a comic you know he is
the thing is though i think a big part
of this is like you're the host you know
so he's such a like a generous
one you guy you want asking you the
questions yeah because he's like yeah
he's a comedy writer like right heart so
he's like really helping
the bits move along oh the best you know
that's kind of the best yeah but i think
colbert is like that too have you done
colbert yeah yeah and he was he was cool
super cool oh all right yeah i was
worried about him you never know you get
to read sometimes yeah no he because
like he comes from remember like uh
strangers with candy
yeah and he's like
his like his roots are like improv actor
you know true but isn't it kind of nice
now with the way things are going
you got podcasts you got your own studio
you got arenas you don't really need the
couch before that was a make or break
and now it's like i'll be fine now it's
gravy yeah yeah now like it could go
horribly wrong and then we would just
talk about it on the podcast exactly you
know you'd be like i don't know people
we would just make memes about it yes
yes yeah 10 years ago i was like oh my
god my life is over yeah yeah now obama
is almost like a badge of honor
yeah it's it's kind of cool i think when
things go wrong and you have like this
like yes this would be like the best
thing for to have after something
publicly went wrong right you know i
think it's stefan obama was it wendy
williams or something something like
that
the cannon maybe the cannon yeah
i think the cannon was having a kid
but yeah you got to use it and then now
we have the power i don't feel like we
had that 10 years ago right you have the
power to every i mean like i i talk
about you guys uh on podcast how much i
love
the um
that thing that started with with with
comics finally going oh i'll just shoot
it myself and put it up hell yeah right
and that thing has just grown and grown
and grown and it's the best thing but
it's all about like
comedians
like taking the ownership it's like you
know it's no different than
somebody wants to be a filmmaker and
they're like right like dude just go
shoot the thing like go make it and also
touring has changed i remember because i
i just did the thing with uh letterman
on the couch on on netflix and yeah and
he was kind of like so you just like he
kind of does he's from a different era
so he was kind of like you know we would
try to get a sitcom he was like can you
explain social media to me which is like
i'm like i'm telling david i'm
explaining social media to david
letterman right but he was like yes
well the money's on the road now
and you can just make stuff i mean of
course you know you you could do a
sitcom still but it's way harder and he
was kind of like so you self-produce it
he just didn't understand yeah it's it's
like a whole new thing it makes sense
that he wouldn't like it'd be new to him
yeah of course
but you're right i mean the one thing i
will say is like now it is on us to
decide when something's ready because
you have to you know back in the day
with these gatekeepers the one thing is
like
i mean look obviously bad specials get
made but you you want the most polished
product to send in and now you can just
be like yeah it's ready and you're like
maybe it's not people will decide on
youtube i guess i don't know yeah yeah
yeah i mean knowing when it's ready is
this skill you learn how do you i mean
is it harder for you to tell now because
like your fans are die hard and then you
came up like a road dog good point yeah
i see what you mean i think you can get
lost in um thinking that you're great
easy right like if you don't have that
thing in your head that goes like
that's like you know but you just i feel
like
you
the only reason you fall for it is like
you got lazy right you know i mean
you're you're allowing
it's like being like i don't need to
lose weight yeah like you just know you
just know you're like i need to [ __ ]
let's trim down you know you just know
right and i feel like you can
you know you can be delusional about it
if you want and you know it you know it
from the stage you know if something
like
uh if it's all fans
the real thing is like if you're doing
all fans and you're kind of like trying
to like muscle a joke in that's like not
working but you're like i'll just keep
that like that's lazy just being lazy
you know but i feel like you have to you
develop once you do this a while
you actually know when to call and be
like hey this is ready right you can
just there's like a you can feel it you
can feel it it's almost like when a girl
fakes an orgasm you're like
i don't think that was real and then
when it's israel you're like
i'm squirted all over like that was that
was the one that was it but yeah but
then there's some comics who were a week
in who are like oh this is all this
bringer show this is all real like i'm
just this is a new comic i make every
woman come yeah i think you do i don't
think you do i don't think you do no we
like i mean i was just taping something
and it's like there's certain jokes
where you're like you're really fighting
for and they just aren't working and you
just have to be honest with yourself
like
i can have like maybe a quick one for me
but you can't put a whole yeah you can't
put out a whole thing for you that's not
hidden no you got to keep cutting and
you're like it's funny certain bits even
my director's like it's a it's a really
good bit i was like but it's not working
right so if it's not working i'll i'll
back to the drawing board yeah and
you'll get it working later and the
thing is you can't you learn this over
time too you can't rely
on other people for it it's got to be
you because you can you can hear the guy
go that's great and be like see it is
great
and like yeah let that be the deciding
factor right i mean but you're the one
that has to go no right
like because you know more than anybody
about whether it's working or not it's
the do i look fat in this and yeah i'd
be like well yeah yeah you know
told you you look fat yes yeah that's
what i tell it and it's like it's i
remember it tell is so
wise and it's like it's like comedy yoda
where it's like the shortest amount of
words you just i remember i heard a guy
complaining about
not getting stuff and it tell just said
get funnier that's it not in a way that
like you're not funny but like what else
can you do yeah and i was like that's
per that's all you need to hear that's
all you do yeah i heard um what was that
rogan said he goes be undeniable that's
the big one yeah i mean that's that's a
great one right undeniable yeah where
people are just like this guy's [ __ ]
you know what can we what can you what
can anyone say right that's what the
road is it makes you undeniable because
you're like is this joke funny in
portland and saint louis sorry is this
funny everywhere you know yeah yeah i
heard a bill bird talk about tony v and
he was like a new comic and tony v was
like this boston kind of legend guy and
they're all hanging out smoking cigars
and billboards like i don't know man i'm
all about jokes but i don't want to be
one of these schmoozers and network guys
and i can't do that [ __ ] and tony v goes
get good at it and that was it and
you're like that's all you need to hear
yeah yeah
yeah
it's a business so many funny people who
put no work into the other stuff and
like you know we we started learning
like holy [ __ ] there's a whole other
side to this you have to yeah you have
to especially now
like you know 25 years ago you could i
pretty much like rely on
like the other people
to manage you and make things happen but
now everybody's like you're legitimately
an entrepreneur oh it runs like samurail
inc and you know mark norman inc and
like like you you run those businesses
and you can [ __ ]
you can you can be like you know what
like we have a few stores open and i'm
happy with that or you have to be like
you know what i have to do this all that
like i have to do all the parts of this
i'm the ceo you have to or if you don't
want to you can just be like well you
know i just worry about the being funny
part and that's obviously the main
product but if you're gonna just be lazy
about it then you don't get to complain
yeah you know because i remember like
friends being like
you know like really funny guys
really funny and being like
hey like
i think i i think i'm gonna start like
submitting to the
the comedy central and the
conan and stuff like that stuff that you
did like five years ago and i'm like
yeah
yeah
and they're like
they're like yeah i just need to start
paying attention to your career yeah
they're like yeah i just you know i'm
like hey all you like you you're ready
you've been ready like you just you have
to act i know but what about the fact
that most comics are inherently lazy do
you ever get worried you have so much
you have so many plates spinning
you got a book you got a podcast studio
you got the road you got family you got
kids wife yeah how do you do it
are you terrified
um
i think
part of it is just you just don't
stop you just keep going you just keep
going yeah are you exhausted yeah
i can't imagine because i mean we're
beat and we don't have families i mean
and we drink and we drink yeah we but
that's we're going to have to cut back
this tour the way that i did this tour
is not the way to do it why is that
because i just signed up for way way too
much like i signed up i usually like we
had like a rule
which was like like two weeks a month
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
me
and if this thing just it was one of
those things where it
it just you know like keep starting
it built building and then it was built
like
way before it started right it was like
it was like down the line
and then you got to it and you're like
what the [ __ ] is this
and then
i've gotten through
you know we're all like just eyeing june
we're like this will be like
but then you know i was looking i was
like july is insane
uh august i have a little break
and then
yeah i mean i
once i get to december i i chill for the
month of december okay and then but then
next year the first
four months are all international stuff
that's that's thank god i think they
just lifted that you need a test to get
back in the country for whatever reason
that just stressed the [ __ ] out of me oh
yeah when i was in canada the second
gary veeder and i landed we had to get a
cover test because we were there for one
night and i was like i [ __ ] hate i
know i [ __ ] hate this silly yeah
mexico i went to mexico um they do it
yeah what yeah what's america oh getting
back yeah yeah i was like oh mexico when
do they start giving a [ __ ] you can
bring
kids home and [ __ ] you know yeah they
don't they don't need a pazakova town
they come here illegally all right
yeah and i feel like i feel like if you
were positive they're like you wanna do
it again
[Laughter]
all right that's what it is but that
even like you're doing a colbert night
does it stress you out just like [ __ ] i
gotta take another test
just a false positive yeah you know i i
didn't even remember and then uh i got a
text this morning like but right before
i got in the car to come here and
they're like hey there's a nurse at your
door
oh [ __ ] and then the nurse came in did a
kova test yeah wow that was a sex she
was good all right oh yeah sexy light
skinned
oh [ __ ] i had a question hold on about
the goddamn work piling up but now i
look oh my thing is whenever work is
like crazy you know you look at your
calendar you're like 10 am phoner
noon podcast three o'clock whatever and
then you have four shows a night then a
flight then this and that i'm like
it will end yeah that's what i always
tell myself like this will this is hell
and it's terrifying but it will stop at
some point yeah i mean it sounds like
you know real zen cliche [ __ ] but you
really do have to go like
here's what i'm doing like in this
moment yes and today it's true yeah you
just have to i do that all the time like
when we got to this special last week i
was like i'm taping seven shows i'm a
[ __ ] idiot it's daunting i'm just
looking at like saturday late show the
second i get off i'm like i'm gonna get
drunk it's gonna be easy i can't wait
and then of course you don't think about
like oh yeah i'm traveling the next day
i feel [ __ ] horrible deal with that
when it comes but but i do think of like
you gotta just look at the
the end because i mean you're so busy
you got your mom's house you've got two
bears yeah you've got and then are you
ever kind of like i want time to write
my [ __ ] act because like we got into
this to be stand up yeah and there's no
time to write i mean luckily the uh
you know
once you're like touring obviously for a
bit your hour gets into like you're like
all right this is like a shaped hour
yeah so it's like that right now where
i'll go i'll perform it all week but
i'll fly home and then we'll record
podcasts all day monday all day tuesday
and then i'll leave wednesday yeah so
it's like it is the entire [ __ ] thing
the other thing that's like i've never
done
really before on tour is that
like we have a huge
like a
workout thing
on the road because i think it's the
only way that i would survive this tour
yeah like if i was like what kind of
work 10 years ago me it would have just
been like let's sleep all day yeah and
then eat in bed right
and then probably die on the door
but now we went well toward tom segura
oh man we wake up
sorry
i just made it real dude what the hell
yeah i got a problem supposed to make it
real and i've had one sip yeah you know
oh [ __ ] he's drunk
yeah he's [ __ ] hammered
his favorite comment big ralphie fan
[Laughter]
now we wake up and we lift
like in the morning what yeah and then
we do cardio before the shows oh you do
like two hours
two two workouts in one day yeah yeah
who's on the who's on the who's doing
this with you train i bring a trainer on
the road wow
that's the most it's funny to think i'll
add more work and that'll make me feel
better you know your energy right a
hundred percent works
because like don't forget that i'm doing
like most of these weeks i'm in a new
city every day exactly so like we'll go
like you know it's like baltimore next
we're in cleveland it's like you know
what
are you up yeah it's like let's just go
now yeah you get up you work out and
then you're like man like you you get
all those [ __ ] endorphins
pump and then we're like now we go eat
like a healthy
breakfast then we have a window at time
it also makes like the time go and then
you know oh i gotta zoom i gotta do this
and then it's like hey it's four let's
go do cardio and then it's like hey
let's go to the shows and then you sleep
better too i bet i mean that's i would
hate opening for you i mean this sounds
like a nightmare because are there more
like i just can't i can't do it kind of
but you know some of those mornings you
get like what are you [ __ ] made of
are you a [ __ ] so it's like that's your
trainer yeah yeah respect shout out to
sean nicks and then um i love i mean
burt and you like bird is getting [ __ ]
faith through the night yeah you go with
him you do that except you don't look
like him but you [ __ ] but i i do but
i don't he doesn't do the workout [ __ ]
like that no no i know he's playing
frisbee golf yeah he's starting he's
funny he's like he's like i'm gonna
completely change my life and i'm like
okay
and then he'll be like look what i did
today and it'll be like i ran four miles
i did a crazy he'll do like a crazy
crazy workout and i'm like dude this is
awesome congrats and then i see him
uh post a story he's like third bottle
of wine and it's delicious and like dude
you can't [ __ ] yeah all that and have
three bottles of time are you out of
your mind he'll post a clip be like
that's cardio i held the phone up you
know that's a few calories you're like
that's not working out but he does i
will say we did europe together and i'd
wake up at noon and he was on the
elliptical he's like crazy what are you
doing he'd have a bud light in the cup
holder of the elliptical it was insane
it's insane yeah crazy he really is a
machine do you uh you still party hard
like every night on the road or no not
every night but uh i get one like one
big night in on you know thursday friday
saturday weekend friday's usually the
big one the big night out but it's now
getting older on this fully loaded thing
you're definitely going to throw it out
i know and then diaz is there and big j
and uh diaz is going to give you guys
all [ __ ] stars you know i can't [ __ ]
with that [ __ ] dude
you know what he'll do he'll do that
he'll be like what are you a [ __ ]
momo and then he'll he'll be like you're
not gonna do it [ __ ]
yeah it's like like a little chicken
and then he'll like he'll cut a corner
off eat that okay and you'll be like all
right and then an hour later you'll be
like
have you done that with him yeah dude
i can't do that dude freak out so i did
his uh podcast like i don't know how
many like seven eight years ago
and he's like eat one of these i'm like
no and he's like why not i'm like
because it's [ __ ] 800 milligrams yeah
yeah so he cuts a corner off like i'm
telling you he's like eat that
and i'm like all right like this
literally it's like you could put it
between these two little things
you know it tastes like you're eating a
crumb of a cookie or something right so
i'm like this is fine i sit there we do
the podcast like this by the end of it
i'm like
and i don't realize how [ __ ] up i am
right i'm like all right it's good to
see you man
i go downstairs i have my
car out front
i get on i put on the the the directions
and it's like make a right onto the
freeway
and i drive straight and i was like oh
[ __ ] it was like it was right there
so i go all right i'll turn around so i
turn around and now it says make a left
on the freeway i drive past it again i'm
like [ __ ] oh boy so then i turn
around again and as i'm pulling up to
that entrance i'm just i mean i'm not
doing anything wrong but i look to my
left and it's lapd and i'm like like i
just like panicked you know oh yeah so i
instead of turning on the freeway i'm
like don't get on the freeway you're too
[ __ ] up i just go straight i pull on
to ventura which is like the big street
in the in the valley
i pull into a ralph's parking lot
and i just put the car in park and i'm
like [ __ ]
and i just turn my head to the right and
in the car next to me
looking at me like this is dice
no way yes i swear to god and i'm like
and i feel like you know i'm tripping
right now yeah yeah in my mind
and i'm like there's no way i can drive
right there's no [ __ ] way i can drive
so i call an uber and
the you left your car you left my car at
the raptor wow and i'm so [ __ ] up that
like first of all the uber driver is a
woman which is pretty like kind of rare
i guess
and i'm like i'm cool don't worry she's
like what
i'm like i'm like yeah there's no way i
could do this right now i keep telling
her i'm like there's no way i could do
this she's like okay i'm like because
i'm like super [ __ ] up and she's like
great
and i just keep repeating it to her and
yeah i'm like yeah you know i was like
just all the turns you made there's no
way i could handle it she's like
all right man like meanwhile diaz is
doing his taxes he's not even facing
he's fine and he also ate like three ah
yeah and what he would do is he would
you know the funny thing he would do the
pockets he would talk at you
for like
70 minutes right and then i was robbing
this guy
and then you're like god and then
literally i got so many messages don't
take the drugs oh dude i got all i got
all those messages don't take the drugs
i was like all right you talk so much
and you actually feel like you're like
at a show or something right yeah you're
listening to it right and then like
you're so like kind of mesmerized by all
the wild [ __ ] and then he's like what's
going on with you and you're like after
that
and then i'm like i don't know i uh i
just you know i have a book out and then
you look at him he's like oh yeah he's
like zonked well you know what's crazy
is that like you're doing colbert it's
like we're sending a covert nurse we're
gonna take care of you you do joey's
pockets you're gonna get drugged right
more people might listen to this oh yeah
crazy good question that's crazy this
guy's kidnapped a person
yeah
this guy pled down from armed kidnapping
wow
arms that's a credit
he was supposed to do 25 years damn whoa
how do you get out of it the the lawyers
they got to plead off he gave him if he
pled guilty to a lesser charge and he he
took it and yeah wow it's funny what we
get in trouble for you know people like
he's he said this on a podcast you're
like well he also
put a person in the truck
that's fine yeah he had an uzi with it
yeah
we're not this is not the same levels
we're doing this
yeah oh you could be mad about that yeah
like
oh that's a comedy special
diaz buying an uzi oh that i'd like to
see
in jersey somewhere that
that is crazy that you were
i mean that scares me on these pods like
the drugs and then you're just like so
this is just in the world now forever
recorded me [ __ ] up oh yeah yeah yeah
that right us having a drinking podcast
i just realized i mean colin quinn said
it he's like you get in trouble what you
say now and all we do is talk into
microphones for the world to hear that's
it it's weird that's what colin said he
goes they said something like could you
get canceled because yeah all you need
is wi-fi yeah yes that's the column i
mean dude i watched some of his new
one-man show last night killer amazing
yeah really i mean what's the new topic
or whatever it's like it's just it's
social commentary it's just the kind
it's just like the world
media yeah but it's god's handling he's
so funny yeah he's such a smart guy yeah
i mean
uh
yeah i was just watching next to liz the
seller and we're just [ __ ] like it's
like
you forget how fun our job is sometimes
you just like you're like oh no i'm
doing this and you're like oh no that's
colin quinn i'm gonna go sit and watch
oh yeah yeah i mean that's the best part
you know totally yeah it is the best
part i mean i i'm still uh
ultimately like just a huge comedy fan
yeah that's why you get into doing
stand-up yeah you just love watching it
i forgot to tell you rock gave you a
nice shout out on david spade's pod i
don't know if you heard that i heard i
heard that yeah pretty cool that was
very cool yeah we see one of you dudes
starting now like
the biggest because it's a big part of
it too is like your age right like how
old are you uh 35 you're 35 and 38 38
like so i'm i just turned 43
and so when i was a i guess i would have
been a i think a junior in high school
bring the pain came out so you're like i
mean imagine you know you're 17 oh dude
and so it's like that's really like a an
age where you're like forming you know
you form your sense of humor but you're
like what is like what is the thing you
know and it's like that comes out you're
like oh that's the that's that's it yeah
and then i'm a what a sophomore or
junior in
in college and bigger and blacker comes
out and we're like what the [ __ ] man i
remember i remember having the like the
cd player and listening to i think it
was roll with the new and i'm laughing
my ass off and like i probably didn't
get half the jokes i was a child but i
was like this is funny i know this is
funny and my mom grabs the headphones
and puts it on i just see like this look
of horror on her face which is what you
want which is what you want yeah
30 seconds later she keeps listening i
see her laughing like that that's comedy
yeah that's [ __ ] comedy like pushed
her away and then pulled her back in the
[ __ ] that's the genius of rock yeah i
was i was to say i was a fan is is like
a huge understanding was he like your
number one guy definitely i mean i was
doing i could show you
i was doing a poor rock impression
really on stage unknowing like you know
when you start sometimes you don't know
that sure
is white and black yeah yeah and i'm
skinny in it yeah you should see it oh
really yeah i'm like one eight pull it
up uh it's it's not up oh yeah
um i i have it though oh i have it but
i'm like i'm like pacing the stage yeah
and i got the free hand and i'm like
punching with this hand
and like and i and another jacket and
then people know people would be like i
remember someone would be like you're
very urban oh wow what and i know this
is like one year in sure and i'm like i
don't realize that i'm just
imitating a cadence that i worship right
of course so i can't help it you can't
help and then now like i've run into him
a few times and i'm absolutely like a
child you know saying like he goes uh
he goes uh hey uh like all your stuff i
always watch all your specials and you
know you got great stuff and i was like
i'm almost i i watch your stuff too
[Laughter]
yeah i told this story before but uh he
he directed a special eye open for just
opened yeah i had a rough one and he
never talked to me never spoke to me you
know he's one of those kind of
standoffish guys but
i had a rough set on one of the shows
and he came up to me and he goes and i
was like oh my god he's coming to talk
to me he goes you got to pick it up and
i was like
okay
and luckily the second set was better
but i wanted to kill myself for like an
hour
and he was right but hearing that guy
say that yeah [ __ ] stung oh yeah yeah
it's one of those things you'd never
forget those things oh never never
that's like a nightmare you have yes
that's a good nightmare you're like
chris rock is like you're not doing well
enough i know that's a [ __ ] nightmare
i had a i [ __ ] it's not the same
thing but i
did a show where uh the director pt
anderson you know he did like oh yeah
oh yeah they're like oh dude phillip
baker hall just died by the way he did
he just died 90 years
as hell and everything
so good like that voice yeah those eyes
yeah i mean i mean
no no
we might be drunk is thrilled to welcome
our new sponsor fanimal
i love live events i hate buying tickets
the hidden fees suck and coordinating
with your friends is the nightmare
they're garbage i always end up fronting
a bunch of money and chasing down my
friends to get reimbursed not me
personally because i'm very generous but
if they flake i'm stuck with a whole
bill and then i discovered fandable
fanable has tickets to everything
there's no fees the price you see is the
price you pay that's i mean that's
pretty big yeah
not only those prices transparent but
they're almost always lower than
anywhere else i look and for any hot
ticket like coachella a laker game or
dave chappelle fanimal is always the
cheapest option nobody gives nobody goes
to live events anymore so why buy
tickets alone fanimal although if you do
come to a show alone there's nothing
wrong with that honestly i love that
someone tweeted me about that the other
day they're like i wanna is it weird my
friend's bails are weird if i come alone
i said no dude enjoy yourself yeah and
you know what the guy made new friends
at the show
afterwards i sat with these guys and
they were tweeting me too so you end up
having a great time no matter what
um
fanimal's patent group purchase makes it
easy first you set a minimum size for
your group and you choose the number of
tickets you want to pay for yourself
then you invite friends when the minimum
size is met everyone gets charged and
receives their ticket if the minimum
size isn't reached in time nobody gets
charged you don't commit until your
friends you march tell them about mark i
called you march
march march normand tell them how to do
it oh yeah and family has amazing
customer service don't take my word for
it check out their hundreds of five star
reviews the next time you need tickets
go to fanimal.com and sign up with
code drunk
for 20
of credit 20 of credit towards your
first purchase we drink on this show
check out fanimal and experience more
support the show and get 20 off your
first purchase with the code drunk at
fanimal.com f-a-n-i-m-a-l
dot-com get on it hey we might be drunk
is brought to you by sheath underwear i
i won't even look i bet i'm wearing them
right now
oh
there they are i'm not i'm not today but
i usually am he usually is i can vouch
i've seen his [ __ ] the official two
pouch underwear of comedy fans
everywhere sheet underwear has been
cradling nuts and schlong since 2013.
who wrote this my aunt
we love them you'll love them they got
it for men women it's the best they're
soft they're sexy they're slick they're
sleek you got the balls and the nuts
separated finally they need some meat
time plus it's invented by a army
soldier and comedy superfan robert
patton he knew there had to be a better
way to unstuck the junk and sheet was
born futuristic dick pouch aside this
underwear is comfy cool and comes in so
many different patterns you can have a
sheath pair ready for any occasion and
they didn't leave out your lady drunks
either
the comfort you guys know for your balls
sheath has applied to boobs with the
sports bras tell them how to do it fatty
while we're drinking i might need one of
them
uh go to sheathunderwood.com and order
with promo code drunk to get 20 off your
first order and sheath 100 money back
guarantee that sheath underwear dot com
promo code drunk
get sheath underwear and let them
support
your ball bag yeah what more do you need
wearing them right now
hey we might be drunk is brought to you
by fume fume is the safe way to quit
smoking handcrafted fumes 100 canadian
maple inhaler is made to comfortably
replace the hand-to-mouth habit simply
insert one of their non-addictive
flavored cores
cores come in dozens of flavors like
peppermint or lemon berry bliss
i got one of these things it feels good
to hold it's it's a cool looking little
uh wooden
contraption and you just want to hit it
all day and it this this thing works and
it smells great it's aromatherapy and an
inhaler
uh there's no smoke no vape no nicotine
to worry about even if you're not trying
to quit smoking fumes
cores can help with relaxation energy
and more it just feels good to put that
puppy in the mouth and give it a give it
a suck give it a whirl folks tell them
how fatty it's like a kid on a flight to
orlando you want to hit it all day
whether you're a smoker or an ex smoker
who still struggles with cravings fume
is the perfect tool for you it's time to
create positive habits and quit
naturally with fume and we're here to
make it easier right now if you head to
breathefume.com
drunk and use promo code drunk you're
going to save 10 off your entire order
you're going to save on the cigarettes
you aren't buying and save on your
initial purchase of fume that's 10 off
your entire order when you head to
breathefume.com
drunk and use code drunk
yeah
but i'm at the show and they're like
paul thomas anderson is here with uh my
rudolph and i was like no way
and i go out there and [ __ ]
i
i tell a joke
that a woman stands up and goes you
should leave
and it's just you know i mean it's just
silent and
then i go why don't you [ __ ] leave
and i go and i get like you know that
natural sure [ __ ] off thing
but it you know to say that the set went
off the rails it was like kind of an
understatement yeah like it was just
like and then
i was like where's pt and they're like i
think he's still out there oh
damn man that is
in your head you're like there's gonna
be another ensemble drama yeah i'm going
to be the new john c reilly
wahlberg whoever they cast exactly dude
it
i remember once in uh that club rooster
t feathers um i'm doing a huge won't go
back to itself really yeah i didn't mind
that one i'll i'll tell you later oh i
can't wait well mine is quick i mean it
was
what you said reminded me of i was doing
a bit that was like i guess turned out
to be a somewhat
uh provocative joke like only joke i've
ever gotten death threats for but like i
was working it out there so it was even
worse i was drunk at the time yeah and
then i remember in the middle of the bit
a woman stands up it's the alligator
joke
and a woman stands up
and she goes
you [ __ ] stink and just paw and
everyone's just is frozen and she just
walks out
slams the door
and uh and then a woman goes i think
you're doing great and that [ __ ] hurt
worse that hurt worse that hurt worse i
was like that's pity yeah
hate me rather than pity oh yeah you
know yeah pity i remember one time
a small audience and a lady there was
like a table at 12 and that was like 85
of the audience and i'm like just like
two minutes in where you're like you
know
engaging feeling things out you're just
kind of like throwing things out she
goes come on
and i go man what's that and she was
like come on he was helping you out
like a toddler yeah she was like you got
it
yeah wow that's condescending oh my god
i've never heard of that one that's
another level i [ __ ] snapped yeah
and then they leave
and then the next day the owner's like
did you
call a lady a [ __ ]
and like a one i go i don't think it
went like that and she's like that was
that was the whole show that was them
they were the show i was like nah it
didn't go like that right i had to like
describe the situation there's always
more to it we're not just going hey [ __ ]
hey yeah [ __ ] of course yeah no but if
you don't i've always said if you don't
have at least like a meltdown on stage
every once in a while at least in the
early years yeah you're not doing enough
sets like you should be melting down at
some point yeah like somebody who
doesn't have a horrific bombing story
i'm like oh you haven't done that much
stand up right right yeah and also like
it [ __ ] every once in a while you get
a bomb where you're like oh i feel like
i stink a fish for like a week oh yeah
you feel like you're just like wow that
was [ __ ]
you can't shake it yeah i remember a few
at like village lantern or those rooms
villager i was like oh wow this is
brutal i remember i tried to fight a
dude i can't fight yeah yeah that's how
that's how how far he pushed me i was
like you and me outside he was like oh
no i just looked insane yeah he ruined
my set it was like six people in there
he's heckling me i'm like i can't i
can't knock out a heckler when i'm
bombing for six people right i just have
to take an l well
those sets they tap into other things in
you like childhood and how much you hate
yourself and self-loathing it all comes
out it all comes out yeah it all comes
out what happened to rooster t feathers
it was that um it was a an exchange with
like it was one of those like you know i
don't know five or six show weekend
sunday they're like we don't know if we
should have the show because there's
like 11 people here oh boy and i was
like all right i mean you tell me right
and then they're like we're having it so
okay
and i got into some
exchange with like a lady but
it was one of the things where like the
waitress
reported it
but she misreported like the exchange
she did like one
one version of the exchange i was like
no
so like the the email was from the owner
and she was like i heard you know you
you said like i go look it started like
i started telling you she's like my
waitress said that you said this and i'm
like you're you're hearing half of the
story yes and then she wrote like i
thought and then she wrote all caps a
headliner who would know how to work
like like a show like this or whatever
so i forwarded out my time to my to my
agent and he was like just don't respond
and i'm like really like this feels like
the thing to respond to yeah yeah he's
like no no i go okay well
i will never go there again i've thought
about
uh doing it she didn't respond
uh well we had a back and forth for a
while but like when she like then
started to throw that in there i was
like i go you're you're literally
telling it's like one side of this thing
and i go and you're not deciding what
the [ __ ] comic and who's playing the
venue also i'm like the audience was on
my side i was trying to tell her like
how like you're your server was it
eleven people in the crowd yeah i was
like and then and like this is brutal by
the way to end a weekend it's the worst
but i'm like the the cheering was for me
yes on what i was saying to this person
and she's just like i heard that you
berated somebody and i'm like no that's
what i go up and do is berate people
that's my act did you ever record it at
least dude it was so long ago i mean it
i don't remember i really don't remember
it was so so long ago but damn not a
great sign for a club when they just
immediately assume yeah liner sucks and
he's a dick and you're like what are you
doing here it was so long ago yeah damn
yeah remember that happened to me once a
comic strip which was like my home club
start now but uh
these seven dudes were shit-faced we'd
go on at the end of the night late night
and these dudes were just [ __ ] with
me like just a bunch of bros being like
we're gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you and
i was just like i mean jesus christ i
was like you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] just
going back at each other and then
someone runs back to get like get a
bouncer in here he's gonna get the [ __ ]
kicked out of him yeah there's seven of
them and the bouncer was like they said
they didn't do anything i was like
you're signing with these dudes they
said they didn't do anything that's
hilarious you're taking their word for
it did you ever work the uh cleveland
improv no i do i do hilarities a lot of
these that's [ __ ] one of my favorite
five clubs to me i love nick
nick's the best it's dude it's the best
club cleveland province can be
rough rough is that urban and uh yeah
yeah primarily but uh you're doing your
one rock there i was yeah
but i remember i was in the back of the
like back of the showroom yeah and the
features on stage and there's like a
table because the room has a weird
layout but there's a table like near the
back of like a big table like 12 and
they're having a full conversation right
like full just like yeah well you know
afterwards like just like that and it's
during the show
so i i kind of i stand next to the wall
one of the security guys i go hey
and i point to the table like
address that yeah he goes what do you
mean to say i go
stop talking right and he's like
i don't want to do that
[Laughter]
like he's just like scared yeah
i mean that's one of those clubs where
they have a
they have a police officer in the
like at the bar fixed which is like he's
there every show
saw a guy get arrested there wow because
he didn't want to pay for the uh it said
one pound of wings
on the menu he goes that wasn't a pound
i know a pound away and they're like
it's the [ __ ] pre-frozen weight yes
he's like nah
so they're like look man it's 12 bucks
and he's like i'm not paying for that
and so they bring him into the showroom
it's like my weekend and they bring him
in the into the lobby area and the cop
goes he tells me the story he goes i
told him
you can you can either pay for this or i
have to arrest you and he just goes
whoa
wow got arrested
is that this is not a pound wing how
much respect that dude i know that's
crazy i was at the dayton funny bones
years ago i had to open our black guy
and this one guy was in the crowd
heckling whatever and then he wouldn't
pay the bill he was like you guys gave
me free tickets so i thought the whole
thing was free like i thought the beer
was free the booze the food was free
and also we got your uber home too yeah
yeah technically yeah you get your rent
and your mortgage it's a good business
practice yeah
you said free show that's a free show
you know i got food drinks and they were
like sir come on we're gonna have to
call the police and he's like call him
call him and it was getting weird and
the opener paid and i was like why are
you paying for this guy he's like black
guilt because he was a black guy he was
a black guy and he felt weird and that
was the first time i heard black guilt
wow
interesting uh yeah that's that's weird
yeah very strange shout out to that guy
i thought he was going to be like i just
want the show to get derailed no no this
is after the show it's just us sitting
there with that guy like i'm not leaving
calling cops that was uh i mean some of
those clubs i remember like hyenas there
was a club in in texas and they just uh
they
they basically banned me because they
won the show would start like an hour
and a half late and i was just i would
say like you guys can't start the show
an hour and a half late like it was like
a 10 30 show starting like 11 40 and i
was like i'm going on at 12 20. crazy
you know so i was kind of like you guys
got to not do that and then i would just
go up there and i would trash the club
on stage and then the guy emailed my
agent and was like if you don't drop him
i'll never book one of your clients
again
and i and she didn't have my back enough
right she should have had my back more
she was kind of like you need to
apologize i was like he needs to
apologize you know he said he said like
they would do like a [ __ ] shot before
they'd bring you on stage yeah that made
me crazy uh the worst because they i
guess it would yeah whatever no i know
exactly because i
i told them i go you have to stop doing
that
and they go he the manager was like he
was hey can i
um why are you saying like i go you're
derailing first of all it's a circus act
and i go
i have the feature
who just killed right
right you're just ruining the momentum
of this show exactly by this and i'm
like this is horrible and he goes
i'll never forget this he goes you're
the only
person i've ever heard complain about
i go no because rachel feinstein called
me complaining about it i call a
complaint i mean well i told him i go i
might be the only person that has ever
said it to your face
i go but this is horrible and then he's
like well the thing is
the people who do that paid like
50 bucks
to do it so it covers my mc for the week
and i'm like whoa
i'll give you the 50. yeah like i don't
also just pay your [ __ ] cup just pay
yeah not based on a freak show yeah yeah
dude i remember they were oh that drove
me crazy and uh and i was making jokes
about it on stage and he goes this is a
family business
i was like you're doing a [ __ ] shot
oh yeah nightmare family business yeah
what does that matter
so is uh you know epstein
i guess not i don't think that's true
that was no family
there you go business the duggar yeah
what about that guy i don't know was
that something i don't know duggar
yeah yeah he had eight kids right
[Laughter]
that's family
[Laughter]
all right what time is colbert i don't
know
they're not picking you up yeah they're
picking me up i don't remember exactly
you rock a suit on there or no
i brought options um
i'll have i have a suit but i have like
a
casual attire option too i'll just feel
it out it feels like you're doing comedy
in a suit it does and then i feel like
i'm like ah you know i'm like i feel
like wearing like more like what you
know what we wear or like what you have
on in the photo there like just feels
like more like all right i feel like
being funny like this yes right like in
a suit you kind of feel like i'm like a
banker or something you know yeah
whenever i do one of those late nights i
always have to know who else is on
that's so exciting do you know who else
you're on with yeah it's the 40th
anniversary of the watergate um
uh stories woodward and bernstein yeah
what yeah that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool yeah they're [ __ ] amazing
yeah yeah so two amazing writers or
excuse me three now because them and me
i have a new book there we go wasn't one
of the married to nora ephron that i
don't know whoa
that's pretty cool
she's a beast yeah um
yeah so that'll be
we'll see how old are those guys now
they gotta be gonna be late 70s yeah
there you go carl bernstein look at that
wow that's the second husband the one
who dustin hoffman played
oh really all the presidents met whoa
that's exciting man that's a cool you
got it you got to get a story with them
yeah yeah yeah yeah who anyone any
memories are like a late night show
where you're on with like a really cool
guest who you chat with
um
i mean
trying to try to remember i saw brad
pitt was at your show recently that's
pretty oh yeah what was that about that
was rad is that he's the coolest that is
insane it's brad pitt it's so [ __ ]
crazy like we're not the type to get
star trek but it's [ __ ] brad pitt it
is wild when they go um
my tour manager he leans into the
dressing room and he goes hey brad's
here and i was like
i was like all right like because i knew
it was happening you know and i'm like
and then like he comes in he's like hey
oh my god
he's like dude i'm a big fan and all
this and i'm like yeah he goes so this
is what you do
because like there was like a laker game
on and he's like just listening to music
and watch basketball i'm like
yeah
you sound like the best person to do the
road with yeah i was like you guys until
that trainer comes in yeah no that's i
would i want that that sounds [ __ ]
awesome that'd be great if brad walked
in you're like can you give me a minute
oh no no no no he's funny he goes it
goes so he's hanging out for a few
minutes he goes well uh do you need to
prepare and i go i'm prepared
he's like oh okay and then we just like
you know they go all right you know i go
i'm gonna i'm gonna go announce the
oprah this was cool too as like uh just
a fan of
the arts i guess is that i go
i'm gonna introduce the uh opening act
which is ryan sickler that night he goes
oh he goes i want to watch like he
didn't go i'll just wait here he's like
i want to watch the whole show yeah so
i introduced ryan and they took him to
his seat yeah and it was great because
it's
it was february so
everybody's a lot of people still a lot
of masks so i was like oh cause i was
like can you go anywhere like you're
[ __ ]
brad pitt and he goes check this out and
he has so his hair is tucked into a
bucket hat yep and you know he's got
like a
like a jacket on and then he has an
oversized mask so he goes like this
and you literally oh wow you see that
and you're like oh yeah i don't know who
the [ __ ] that is and simply goes looks
like chad pitt to me i was like
but yeah it was like yeah uh
he uh they must have like loki kind of
liked the pandemics of people that found
that famous yeah you know i was all you
ever um have have mascot and someone's
like hey mark yeah
and you're like you feel like it's weird
but then i was at a
coffee place in l.a
and everyone had masks on i turned i'm
like oh that's ben affleck like you just
wow right because like immediately too
like oh with my eyebrows
they're gonna know yeah yeah three
things i love about brad pitt one i saw
him get interviewed and they said what
do you like it was my one of my favorite
things is monty python i was like wow
that's crazy yeah two when he did the
[ __ ] jim jeffrey show he was the
weatherman that was great and then the
coolest the third thing i was watching
jackass in high school
and they push a guy in like a chicken
suit or something
in a shopping cart and he slams into a
wall and the thing flips over and the
head pops off it's brad pitt crazy i was
like this is the coolest guy of all time
you heard my marin's podcast he's just
like you know he's like he's like oh i
love marin on ifc you're like this is
[ __ ] awesome yeah
yeah
and then like you know you see like
those views like i was
i i can't help but re-watch the south
park movie all the time it's like my
favorite movie ever probably team
america are uncut uncut oh yeah i love
team america too but yeah uncut is like
my favorite thing like the fact that
they [ __ ] stuck the landing on a
musical yeah the dumbest thing that is
that brilliant amazing but then you're
just like oh george clooney's just in
this movie yeah oh yeah it's so [ __ ]
he's the reason that south park is even
in existence i heard that yeah he passed
their tape around yeah yeah so like
yeah including this is like 1997.
uh he got the tape
of it and was like i'll give he gave it
to like the viacom people what yeah i
didn't know that how many central people
yeah like a christmas tape or something
yeah right yeah it's crazy yeah he's
crazy
so they yeah they've always had like a
connection wow how do you like that
i couldn't i thought i like couldn't
like clooney moore yeah
yeah yeah dude uh i heard this i don't
know if this is true but when you did
your first netflix special it was when
comedy central was still kind of big and
were you did comedy central say no to
you and you were like yeah is that true
yeah i have the i have like a whole
chapter about it in the in the book but
uh about the
like yeah it's all about like road stuff
and about like how i don't know things
happen and i'm like
i remember that i had done
uh live at gotham which was like oh yeah
10 minutes set yeah that was big then i
did comedy central presents which was
like you felt like this is like how to
do it yeah because that's what we grew
up on that's where we grew up
all those guys and so i'm like all right
i did that and then
this is a
few years later now so i'm like i'm you
know i was like we're talking about
you're ready i'm like i'm ready to do
this hour
so
we shoot oh well i go i want them they
go they want to come see it so i do this
thing i do uh flappers and burbank oh
quit bragging yeah
and but it's a nice like small room it's
a sign like i get it filled up because i
with the podcast at the time i just have
enough juice to go like if you want to
come to this i'll give you like i want
it to be fans and like free tickets i'm
not trying to sell them yeah and it's
packed
and like i go up there i run the hour it
goes great
so i'm like and this is a bunch of
people out there just comedy central
people uh just comment like three comedy
central executives come to the show and
then
uh you know
i i talked to my manager like a couple
days later i'm like what's the what's
the word and they're like yeah they're
like
they thought it was good i'm like okay i
know this call and then but like you
know
they didn't wanna i'm like all right so
then i get a deal to shoot it on spec at
the time so like we'll shoot it and then
shop it mm-hmm so again
we send it to them like now it's like
here it's it's shot now you know so like
yeah and they and it's a little
demoralizing this [ __ ] tap dance you
have to do oh of course yeah very much
so and then the craziest part was like
well the feedback was
what's the theme oh
it's funny funny funny is the theme it's
jokes it's a bunch of jokes yeah and
then i go and i started to go well
what's the theme when i started to name
people's spec what are those themes
exactly and then he's like yeah i mean
it was just he was just like look i mean
it's just no yeah and then he was like
you know
uh hbo you sent it to hbo like i
couldn't believe that people at the time
at the time that was a crazy thing to do
i was like why would you send it to hbo
that's like carlin right
and then he's like well yeah and then
you know we sent it here send it there
and he goes
netflix said they would acquire it and i
was like oh that sucks
[Laughter]
because at the time it was kind of like
netflix
the dvds mail thing i remember he was
like he's like well burr said it's like
really doing something for him and i was
like all right cool
like it was really like i pulled over on
i was like so it's gonna be on netflix
he's like it's going to be on netflix
wow and i was like all right that was
2013. holy and that really i mean that
changed everything right yeah i mean it
came out in 2014
i would say i remember a few
it came out in march of 2014 and like in
june
i did i did the cleveland improv and i
remember at the end of the week the the
guy lee who runs it he goes i don't know
why but you hit bonuses
i cannot figure it out and i'm like all
right and then also people paid for
their wings this time a whole pound and
then by the end of that year i was
selling out clubs
and then by the the next year we were
doing like kind of like rock clubs and
stuff right yeah wow
and also you i heard you blew up on
pandora too because you have albums and
heavy rotation i mean that's how i
discovered you is i would i would listen
to your albums
and i was like oh [ __ ] this is like
this is a this is a cool way to discover
comedians it was kind of like it opened
the door because you were an old-school
comic where like you talk about the
influence of a tale and those guys but
like
you were like one of the last guys i
feel like i discovered from albums
you're i think you're right because i
used to go
then you would make assumptions so
people would come like i'd have a
uh you know a sold out club or something
and i would i would still be like
selling my cd or whatever afterwards so
you meet people meet people leaving and
i would always go like
netflix netflix and like a whole bunch
of people would be like pandora oh isn't
that crazy yes i did uh hattiesburg
mississippi this is probably 2016. i've
done that yeah and i was like you know
half full and i was like hey hattiesburg
half full i'm coming up in the world and
they're like well segura was here last
week he sold out two shows i'm like
who i
i wasn't a who but it was like really i
didn't know you were that big to sell
out hattiesburg yeah you know that was
like a dry not a far drive from
new orleans
so that was a big deal i was like wow
this guy is coming up if he can sell
here yeah
yeah i think that's the thing with like
now with like this tour that i'm on
we really you know i
i call it the i'm coming everywhere
world tour and we do like uh
uh we've done so i mean i've done on
this tour so so far over 200 shows
and like you know i don't know how many
cities but it's it's a lot of cities
and i've done cities i've never done
before yeah and you're just like
you know any pleasant surprises where
you're like oh this is like a cool city
dude
honestly
uh
a bunch but it's always like related to
the show
you know what i mean like because we
don't really
do that much city exploring that's true
because you're in and out you're just in
and out but like you're like
i wonder how the show will be tonight
and you know you're in
greenville or evansville right yeah and
you're like i don't know and then you
have like this
kind of like rock star show you're like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah but i also
feel like
i mean i'm sure you experienced the same
that like when you go to the smaller
markets sometimes they're like so
appreciative yes of the show thank you
for coming here yeah we're like you know
in new york they're like yeah of course
you're doing a show here right this is
new york right l.a forget about it yeah
yeah because sometimes those smaller
cities like as you said to work out
you're like
they're the best because they're
forgiving
yeah and they're in like a bigger city
they're like kind of there there's
almost a sense of entitlement sometimes
you're like
bring it yeah and you live in new york
you might know eight hilarious dudes i
feel like if you live in evansville
there's like one funny guy in the town
oh in new york they're like yeah we came
here over hamilton you better [ __ ]
bring it you know yeah yeah um
chappelle's in town a rockstar town and
i'm coming to see you and everyone in
this city is like fun like the guy
working the like the [ __ ] door is
funny exactly
the bagel guy is funny yeah exactly
there's a funny energy about new york oh
yeah i would talk about this all the
time but like one of my favorite movies
ever is the original taking a pelham one
two three because it's literally a
hijacking on the train and instead of
being like worried everyone's just like
all right yeah what you know right it's
like so new york to me i just loved that
new york like energy but um
dude i can't believe you wrote a book
this is yeah i know i know and i i um so
i on top of everything you're doing you
wrote a [ __ ] book which was so much
more work than i ever would have
imagined yeah and everybody told me too
all comics were like don't do it yeah
yeah i know it sounds like an insane
amount of work yeah and comics don't
want you to have a thing we don't have
right
yeah no but it's um
it was a lot of work i'm super happy out
i i i had brought
copies to like bring the all these
things and then i left them all on my
tour bus uh right before the whole i
want to read it dude
comedy i'll send them to you i'll send
you guys please please put it up in the
studio yeah dude so it's like it's
essays yeah it's like stories and essays
good one oh wow all right all right that
was good thanks for leaning
the other way appreciate it yeah that
was cool
thank you for pushing it this way well i
know you better yeah i appreciate yeah
stories and essays yeah and that's uh
that title is because that's the uh
that's the first full sentence my first
sunset my first song said to me yeah oh
it's amazing like i sat down it's a
great title yeah and he was like i would
like to play alone please i was like
okay cool man what what made you go like
the essay wrote over like i'm sure
people like you they came to you with a
book proposal and you were like this is
well they were like um you know they're
telling me like oh comedians have
written you know humorous things and i
was like well
they go what would you write and i was
telling them like you know it's like
basically stories right you know the
time that this happened uh the time that
uh you know i shared a
a condo on the road with a 600 pound man
uh like i'm telling them these stories
yeah and then they're like well write
you know give us a writing sample so
then i wrote um i think like 10 000
words and then
sent that in like different stories and
they're like yes you could
do a book like this style so then and
then i have like these interstitial
things about
flights
um where i've sat next to celebrities
but it's all black celebrities
tucker chris tucker bruce bruce
chris we talked about chris talking
about a lot too you do i mean money
talks friday rush hour my grandmother's
story is one it is one of my favorite
ones because
i
am sitting next to him and i don't say
anything to him chris tucker he's right
next to me right and i'd seen him at the
gate and i didn't say anything there wow
and
we're just sitting there like
and as the plane is taking off and we're
like we're both facing forward
i just hear him in his you know very
distinct voice he goes should i do
another rush hour
to himself well that's the thing i'm
like he's definitely talking to like i
saw him talking to the guy who's behind
me now
so i'm like he must be talking
to that guy yeah and then i'm like
and then i just turn he's
he's just looking at me oh like you're
asking me dude so i go i don't know man
like this is like verbatim i go
i go i don't know he goes yeah he goes i
was in beijing last week
he goes i'm walking through the streets
i see jackie chan
and he goes what are you doing here i go
i'm here to see you and i go sounds like
the next rush hour to me
he goes i think you're right and then
i'm like yeah he goes yeah i'm gonna he
starts then he starts like writing back
i go you just consulted with me on how
to do this or whether to do this was he
aware of you being a comedian and all
that i tell him next i go i go yeah i go
i did the show because we were actually
on an amphitheater show
the night before but never met he closed
out the first half it was 20 000 people
wow and
i said or something it was like a bit it
was like a one-off thing okay but it was
like chappelle and i never met him i
didn't even see him they just were like
chris tucker was here but i didn't like
since i didn't meet him i didn't start
by you know i just kind of let it go
yeah and then i go yeah i was on that
show last night he goes what and i'm
like yeah man i go i did the second half
and i go i did like way later and i you
know i heard you did great that kind of
thing and then he's like yeah
he goes yeah i got this thing on netflix
and i go yeah i have things on netflix
he goes for real and i go yeah and i go
he i go so now you're done i go so yeah
you're going to see like you know your
ticket sales are going to go
up and
you know you just got to go work out
that new hour and he's like where and i
go in clubs he goes what kind of clubs
i'm like comedy clubs wasn't he a
comedian yeah i'm like what are you
talking about he's like which ones i go
i start like you're explaining comedy to
chris i'm like telling him the club and
then he goes
he goes will you uh will you send me
that list i go of the comedy of the
nations comedy i see him at club
sometimes i see his poster up now really
i was just at the charlotte comedy zone
and then like chris tucker's face he's
like he gave me his phone number he's
like he's like so i texted him like you
need to go to like here here and here
he's like all right thanks man like has
he done your mom's house no you've got
to get him on dude i know
the worst part is you ate a star and
none of that happened
yeah it was it was the best dude wow
he's incredible he's one of the funniest
people naturally so funny gifted he
would like be falling in rush hour and
the noise he would yell out would be
like comic yeah perfection he's so great
yeah i love the uh the um
the bloopers at the end where he's like
jackie and they're like his name is not
jack
in the movie
he's like over and over when he's on the
phone who the hell do you think you
kidnap kelsey grammer it's like it's
chelsea clinton
just like yelling at him yeah he's the
best dude no dude he's we're huge fans i
mean he is an elephant he's going
if someone wants to tag chris tucker
we'd kill to have you on we might be
drunk please love you
we'll get you drunk
i used to watch comic view as a kid and
every comic would literally do a michael
jackson but his was always the best he
had the best dude rush hour too and he's
just doing yes they were probably just
like yeah he can do michael jackson just
write it into this
sure
i forgot he's on netflix i think he's
wearing a polka dot suit am i nuts
pull that up if you can i think i swear
to god who else any other flight people
that are just like tyson yeah mike tyson
serena williams whoa bruce bruce
um what are you flying urban air i don't
know what is that that's my soul plane
bro
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] i know it's so crazy right
oh jill scott
and the funniest is that i write the
chapter about jill scott
and then at that [ __ ]
that pete's thing at the garden
i'm backstage and i think that's jill
scott over there and i just written the
chapter about her and the chapter starts
i go uh
i think the first line is jill scott
hates salmon
because we were on a flight and they're
like would you like
uh you know the salad or the salmon she
was i don't uh-uh no salmon and and i
started talking to her about salmon and
i was like you should try i was trying
to tell her how to eat it so i go over
to her and i'm like hey we flew together
from l.a to nashville seven years ago
and i started telling she's like okay
and i go here's here's my proof that we
did this is i'm not making this up she
was like go ahead and i go you hate sam
and she goes i don't [ __ ] with anything
pink
yeah
wow
all right maybe i was wrong with the
polka dot suit no oh you're right polka
dots shirt shirt that's all i remembered
sorry
uh wow no salmon i love something i know
i love santa too dude i think some money
talks in the theater three times whoa
maybe at least twice yeah one of the
funniest [ __ ] he's outrageously funny
yeah i mean it's he's the coolest yeah
damn
it'll be missed
we're talking about it like he's dead
he's still around he'll be in the movie
what was your favorite part about
writing the book
[ __ ] being done dude yeah i mean you
know what it is i i was just telling
this yesterday that you know when you
watch a special you of yours like you're
doing the edit you're just like a bit
you'll be like i really like this book
yeah like you're proud essentially
you're proud of it you're like i'm very
proud of this bit this is good
and some of the other ones you're like i
don't know it's the same feeling like
with the book
you're like this is a good story this
chapter is good i like the like the the
word play like the whole thing it's
funny it's engaging and then you know
you're like i wish i could [ __ ]
rewrite this chapter right right or cut
this one it's the same kind of feeling
you know but you feel more vulnerable
because you don't get to
perform the way that it's received yeah
it's just the written word so like when
you hand it in you're like
like you're like white you know like
yeah yeah just like are you texting
lines to comics are you running stuff by
christina like no none of that none of
that but i'm giving it to a a really
great publisher editor and a book agent
and like who i'm working with so much
that like their notes are
like it's like getting
stand-up notes from a comic you're like
these are really good notes yeah so
immediately like i
when they were like this is a great
chapter i was like okay thank god
because i you would hand it and be like
is this the worst thing you've ever
written is there anything you read to be
like this is how i i this is like the
style that's right for essays
no because i i mean
i i don't
read a lot now like i have yeah you're
busy yeah i mean i i remember reading
um a couple of comedy like comedians
books like a while ago and i remember
reading like
humor writing story and i just wanted it
to be like
stories that were like engaging and
funny and like you know
specific to the way that i write
so once i was like you know telling
stories i ended up telling a story about
living in florida and going to visit
someone and with my sister and then she
sees something out in a field and makes
me turn around i don't want to turn
around so it's like you know how i write
that story and then we finally go and
it's a body
that uh was in a field oh wow a
motorcycle was like nearby so a guy
clearly so it's like that whole kind of
story but like
when i
read the final draft i was like oh i
like this story you know what i mean
like it's like it has like elements of
surprise it's like it's good
storytelling yeah and it has funny stuff
in it so like things like that would
make me feel i was like oh this is what
i want the book to be full of yeah
stories like this yeah i mean i grew up
reading sign language remember that when
i read couple hood yeah underrated it's
uh what's his favorite paul reiser's
book yeah killer yeah that's great i
read it you know when i was like
18. david sedaris me talking to darius i
read all of that those are funny as hell
i remember um
i don't remember the name of it or which
one but i definitely read a jim norton
oh happy endings was that it great
fantastic so funny he's really really
annoyed we love him he's a funny guy a
smart guy too fat to fish is good party
yeah that was incredible yeah i mean
[ __ ] about his dad his heartbreak i mean
our artists artie is one of the funniest
humans yeah do you see him still you see
him around it's been forever i used to
come around i used to go to his house
and watch my 600 pound life and just him
narrating it in hoboken just just
riffing i'm like dude i will never hear
anything funnier no he's already laying
riffing on my 600 pound life the
funniest dude yeah
dude are you a miami heat fan
no i that that was like i mean miami was
kind of close to where i was in in
florida but i thought you're a big nba
guy no i mean i i like the nba i'm a big
college football fan you were a football
player too right uh i mean high school
you know yeah yeah well i think you're
ohio i was born in ohio oh [ __ ] like i
went to high school in florida so and i
went to high school in florida in the
90s and that was when like florida
florida state and miami were just like
it was like that was the entire that was
all a college football that's all that
mattered i mean they literally football
is your number one sport yeah but those
like those three schools were either
competing for or winning the national
championship i mean literally 91
winning one uh for miami 92 one of them
lost 93 florida state 1 94 i think
florida lost 95 they won 96 like
literally every single year they were
either in it
or winning it one of the three schools
so
it became like and then if you're in
high school and you're around that
you're playing that sport it becomes
kind of like everyone's obsession oh
yeah yeah not to mention the problem you
had dan marino was the guy he was even
an ace ventura yeah for sure it was what
was there have you had a lot of big
athletes at your shows i thought i saw
you posting something about that yeah
yeah there's they've been coming out
joe burrows just came the cincinnati
quarterback yeah he's sexy yeah cool
dude cool dude and then he was like he
goes uh he goes you want to come over
the house after and i was like and my
uncle and aunt were at the show i was
like hey uh we're not going to hang up
dinner afterwards
they're in their 80s i was like i might
not see you again
i see black guys posting about how cool
he is and i'm like this guy's made it
that's the that's the ultimate swaggy
for sure
i happen to we stay you know we're in
cincinnati we're staying across the
street from this like the urban ware
store and we go in there we all buy i
bought like a coogie shirt
and then and then i wear it to the show
and then he comes to that show and he
walks up to him he goes he's like you're
wearing [ __ ] that i would wear man
yeah dude damn but he was uh yeah he was
rad and so
so nice um they all want to be comics
too which is fun because obviously we'd
like to be a pro athlete but we skipped
dinner and he goes uh he goes my chef
made these of you guys one day
we were like wow
what did his chef make really good food
like a paella
and that chicken dish with like brownies
who's your do you have a pro football
team or no well i mean i'm from cincy
originally so i'm like uh you know
he's your guy i mean yeah but i have to
admit that when i left as a kid i left
the year they went to the super bowl in
88
and we were so you know gung-ho on the
bengals and they entered such
a depressing era like a run of being
horrific that it was like it was tough
to say like go bangles when you're you
know watching them go
3 and 13 for like a decade right so i
just kind of like lost interest in it
honestly yeah damn
look at that [ __ ] jacket top gun
looking dude yeah dude
look at jesus christ that looks like a
tv yeah he's so good you do have to win
when you dress like that yeah
you can't show up like that and not win
no
yeah it's crazy to think that he you
know has like
insecurities right he seems so confident
but you were all human you know he's at
home like ah geez i suck yeah or maybe
not maybe that's just me
no i think everybody does everybody does
yeah yeah we've all you know sharded and
yeah said something stupid even like the
guy who you think is the coolest [ __ ]
guy ever exactly yeah yeah brad pitt is
sharded yeah he sharded him yes he's
sure that's nice he's he had a night he
couldn't get it up
yeah you know that's that's nice to hear
yeah he probably can't get it up because
he's so out of [ __ ] though you know what
i mean yeah
there's no way it's a good round yeah
not good enough yeah like dude
that's four lows i'm 58. i'm running on
empty i can't i can't imagine being
tired of [ __ ] angelina jolie at some
point he was like i'm good i'd rather
watch the game yeah it's got to be
awesome i guess so yeah that's when
you've made it yeah that happens that's
why they adopted he was that to come he
was
that's a lot of kids
yeah now you you got i want to have kids
one day you do and you have two i have
two boys yeah yeah this is news to me as
well
you don't want kids at all maybe i don't
know but i've never heard you say it out
loud wait have you tied the knot are you
uh no november so i got a few months
okay so what's happening though oh yeah
it's terrifying yeah but uh where are
you gonna do it are you doing new
orleans
yeah yeah she's from
massachusetts so it's like yeah yeah
november new orleans will be nice that's
the only good month yeah it's either
sweltering heat with humidity or
hurricanes i'm psyched i'm safe for the
wedding it's gonna be fun
and you you're gonna do babies you think
or not all right
yeah we'll figure it out i gotta have a
woman first i think but uh we'll we'll
see
yeah he's a virgin yeah never never
[ __ ] a woman you got to try it it's
great dude i heard it's good it's pretty
good i'm excited to try yeah use your
dick i'm gonna dude
i'm gonna [ __ ] a woman with my dick yeah
hello it's gonna be crazy yeah it's nice
where'd you tie the knot do you do l.a
no
go piss
uh
i did the bahamas what yeah that's
you're that guy who's like hey i'm
getting married in the bahamas and every
comic has to be like you know what's
great is that like it was uh
it gets everybody to something like that
that you'd want to be there
really it really weeds them out that's a
good point so it was like three or four
days or five however many days we were
there
um
35 people but they're like all the
people you'd want to right it's the vips
it's the vips that's that's good it's
kind of great do you do the beach like
barefoot
no no i couldn't because uh my parents
are
way hardcore catholic and they're like
you don't do a [ __ ] beach wedding oh
[ __ ] so we had to go to the church what
yeah like the little old school church
in this little bahamian town that's
pretty cool it was kind of cool it was
in luther or the island of a lutheran
and then um but yeah then immediately
you go back to the place and then right
right hangs out yeah damn i went to
catholic school did you yeah oh really
oh yeah i grew up unreligious but when i
was [ __ ] up so my parents said you
gotta go to catholic school and like get
your [ __ ] together were they catholic
like no no atheists like my parents are
old hippie weirdos but they were like
you're
a piece of [ __ ] kid so you need a little
bit of
some structure
yeah yeah yeah something and then they
are all new to me was it good for you
ah not really i mean it was like they
drug tested it was uniforms it was it
was disciplinarian it was it was wrong
you told me the story like i think you
said you were 16 or 17 and your dad
found you like just hammered yeah i told
you about that yeah oh yeah
found me uh
shit-faced and i had my first like big
job interview that morning and i was
like ah and he threw me in the shower
clothes on turned it on and yelled at me
yeah and uh what do they think now that
you're like the successful comedian and
the you know they're like yeah you
[ __ ] off as a kid but yeah you have
like a real career i don't know it's a
good question really you guys don't
you've never heard them they're on the
show they don't emote really yeah
they're military i don't know they're
nice they're good parents but uh
there's not a lot of like
good on you kid really yeah
but i don't know maybe that's what i'm
striving for okay
oh yeah that is that's your totally
maybe yeah what about you you you got
decent parents yeah i mean um
they were
i mean my dad was very
very supportive oh that's cool yeah and
he was like a big cheerleader you know
what i mean yeah he was real excited
about everything that like even the
early you know open mic embarrassing
[ __ ]
yeah he was like he was
like really like down for going for it
you know damn that's awesome yeah it was
pretty cool was your mom supportive as
well yeah
i mean yes but she was like i remember
her being like you should get the job at
the post office
why and she goes so you have security
and then at night you can do your shows
and i'm like yeah i'm not going to go to
the post office
i was like i'm doing this i mean i was
really struggling do your videos with
your mom are so funny yeah she's she's
hilarious she's really funny she's
really funny like
you did fluent spanish it's pretty good
i mean i it
it was really good at one point it
definitely
uh was going away because i wasn't using
it yeah and then i started to use it
again it's come back a good bit yeah
yeah but it will go away if you don't oh
i spoke french as a kid it's all it's
basically all gone really you did that
yeah and why did you just immersion oh
you know i'm from new orlea it's very
french there yeah sure and my dad's
french and it just it fizzles your dad
your dad's french well it's normal i
mean it's uh it's just like louisiana
french okay no it's not we're not like
eating eating bread and smoking
cigarettes and drinking water no i have
a lot of french blood oh yeah yeah yeah
like my dad's middle name is nadeau
his mother was a french canadian yeah
yeah um yeah so there's there's like a
good bit french culture so cool it's so
rad it's just like pretty great and it
is the thing is you know what the it's
so seductive is that they don't [ __ ]
want you
i don't know oh jesus
or we're not recruiting rather and i
think that gives the judaism thing like
when people come to us they really want
it absolutely you know and the same with
the french they couldn't give a [ __ ]
about anyone else
out of here my dad does not give a [ __ ]
about me
but no i'm just kidding but uh that's
true yeah the movie the old french new
wave movies are so
sexy cigarettes the fact that they drink
all day and none of them are fat yeah i
know except for have you seen gerard dip
her dude he looks like bert it's crazy
oh my god yeah dude it's his nose is
like j it it's crazy when you drink so
much you remember when he was on that
flight oh and he pissed in the aisle yes
he was so drunk he on a [ __ ]
commercial flight gets up and just like
and they're like what are you and it's
gerard departed he's like
he puts out a statement like i apologize
do you see do you see that he claims he
drinks 12 bottles of wine a day it looks
like it's 12. bro
he's that's a lot in a week he looks
rough pull him up pull him up pull up
george
make sure you right now i can't name one
movies and holy [ __ ] look at that
yeah that's not good that's a big man
he's gone like orson welles
yeah look at that photo with the nose
holy [ __ ] yeah
looks like kathy jimmy
holy she looks like he ate mario batali
right there with the uh with the
overalls oh this is you don't see yeah
this you don't think you don't see bert
you know
yeah burt [ __ ] diaz
that is crazy
holy [ __ ] he is
i mean he is
not a healthy look how handsome he used
to be is that him and uh
no he was a hunk yeah wow
yeah look at that well i remember brando
i mean oh the ultimate smoking young
brando smoke shot what's the not street
car with the one where he's on the dock
waterfront on the waterfront he's like
one of the hottest dudes ever ever and
the lips he turned into a goddamn
balloon he was like
like the goodyear blimp dude yeah he's a
big man
dr moreau
that was rough dude the greatest they
just did that val kilmer documentary and
he's welcome just walk around with a
video camera and it's on that movie was
that the movie the island
yeah or it's just it's just rando fetish
[ __ ] laying on a hammock like oh you're
filming you know yeah it's insane don't
meet your heroes
yeah brando is look at that sex come on
son of a [ __ ]
that guy would do what he wanted with
you
oh yeah yeah you wanted him too the cool
one of the coolest actors ever totally
[ __ ] streetcar is incredible too i
mean everything he was in man although
have you seen what's that movie where he
plays a japanese man
what pull that one up
rush hour two
no you're gonna be like holy [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
this is dude this is the [ __ ] that you
used to do you know breakfast at tiffany
[Laughter]
yeah see this is why he went hardcore
for the native americans because he knew
this was in his back pocket yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] but that's when hollywood was
kind of that's what he gave like a
middle finger to hollywood i thought
that was [ __ ] cool
yeah that was before anyone else was
doing it too
that's when they were still like the
club you wanted to be a part of and that
and he was like suck my dick yeah he was
he really was wow he was cool [ __ ] all
right well all right where are you gonna
you gotta i mean do you wanna plug dates
uh yeah i got i got a bunch of uh you
know if yeah topscore.com tour um
there's i i used to like remember i'm
going to be in this city in that city
and i don't anymore there's too many
blur but
check it out
you'll see you'll see a date uh where
i'm somewhere near you please get
tickets and the book i'm very excited
about
if you want to check it out there's i'm
excited there's a hard copy there's a
audio book i did i read the book on
audible wow um and then there's um
there's e-books too if you're into that
so there's copies of everything it's a
milestone man it is huge thanks man man
i hope to never write a book yeah it
seems like a lot of work the um the best
advice i i said i i listened to it for
like
a week
um was tom papa because he's written a
number of books yeah he was like set um
set a
time every day it's not overwhelming so
like an hour 10 to 11. maybe one day
you'll write two pages next day you
write five so if you do it like five six
days a week
you'll have a book just chip away yeah
if you go oh he's great but if you go
like nah i just don't feel like doing it
yeah and then all of a sudden you have
like the pressure building exactly
i almost wrote a book once because uh
dana gould and i wrote a show and we
couldn't sell and he was like just write
it as a book and we'll be able to sell
and i was like hell yeah dude and then i
banged out like 80 pages and i was like
nah i'm good i can't
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
pretty good yeah pretty good but i was
like i'm done but uh
yeah man uh yeah see tom on on tour you
see all the dates up there we'll throw
those up there is that a thing well oh
i'm sorry it says 10 p.m i thought it
was at 12 p.m i was like
you better act because look these are
all sold out already so you better you
better get on these get on it folks
don't miss them oh golden nugget
oh boy lake charles louisiana let me
apologize now
i've been there i've been there okay and
we're gonna be norman uh
marknormancomedy.com i'm all over the
road all the clubs tom is [ __ ] on
i'll be there
i'm back at hyenas by the way yeah no i
got a bunch of fun dates i'm doing the
wilbur doing the neptune doing a great
one yeah and that seems great you've
done it before no never seattle yeah i
did uh my second special there oh yeah
awesome room all right wilbur's also of
course one of the nation's great one of
the best yeah so yeah all kinds of fun
dates announcing uh vancouver toronto
those two cities are [ __ ] amazing
great comedy towns yes
congrats on your new special thanks man
yeah be out uh hopefully august or so
i'm i'm happy with it so
check it out you have a name for it yet
or not yet i think it's gonna be called
same time tomorrow which is uh i like
that yeah it's a it's literally like a
pedophilia joke
but it's also applicable to comedy so
whatever
uh
probably same time tomorrow and then uh
yeah houston improv west palm improv uh
building this [ __ ] back up tampa i
thought the set was nice but maybe uh
get wi-fi next time you know yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] matt nice to know internet
i'll beat the no internet cafe oh yeah
uh we'll be uh no all over uh dania
beach uh san jose improv pittsburgh
improv a lot of improvs yeah building
back up but uh i'll see you guys on the
road and thank you bearded jew for the
drink
beer jew
sorry same [ __ ] thanks so much tom thank
you so much yeah yeah thanks for having
me guys awesome kill colbert fans thanks
brother we're fans thank you so much man
comedy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we
might be
true
[Music]